[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Hi, I'm Reto Meier,
Google Developer Advocate.
Joining me today is Dave
Renson, Director of Customer
Reliability Engineering.
So, Dave, we all
know that SREs are
trained to imagine the
worst possible scenario
and prepare for it.
DAVE RENSON: Uh-huh.
RETO MEIER: Are
there ever scenarios
which you've come
across which have
made you want to pinch yourself
from a waking nightmare?
DAVE RENSON: So you
know, Reto, cats
are the patron saint
of the internet.
We all know this.
It's why there's so many videos.
But did you know that
sharks are the mortal enemy
of the internet?
They're like the grumpy old men.
So we had this
fiber cable once--
RETO MEIER: I'm going to
interrupt you there, actually,
because if you tell
everyone the story now,
they're not going to have
any reason to come to Next.
DAVE RENSON: There are has lots
of reasons to come to Next.
Great technical keynotes, and
other stories that frankly
make the shark story look like
the least interesting thing
you've ever heard.
Join us at Next, and especially
join us at the 5th Nine,
a lounge we have dedicated
for SRE and DevOps people
to come hear all the wonderful,
wacky, wild, and just
plain weird stories of what
it takes to run production
systems at web scale.
RETO MEIER: We look
forward to seeing you then.
[MUSIC PLAYING]